this is Jacob underground podcast number
74 Echo Charles City uh and me John
Kohler willink
just to get everyone a little bit of
sanity
the insult that you hear that that makes
you mad hmm
generally speaking the reason it's
making you mad is that there's some
little piece of Truth in it that's what
bothers you
you are mad because it's true
so
what you should do when you feel that
little anger flare up when somebody says
something to you
is don't let it make you mad instead
just agree with what they're saying
by the way you don't even have any
choice to agree with it because it's
true you know it's true that's why it's
bothering you
so
accept it
and agree with it and say to yourself
yeah there's a that's a good point there
um I wrote about this in Warrior kid
wear the warrior kid
book two
um Nathan James he calls Mark plate face
and you know like look at Mark's face
kind of like round and big it's kind of
true like yeah you look like a plate
dude
and he gets called plate face and he
gets all mad he wants to fight Mark
wants to fight Nathan James
and instead Uncle Jake says hey man just
be like yeah I do have a pretty round
blank looking face don't I hmm
and
that's what you do
now here's a little component kind of
ties into the last thing we talked about
so accept it
but don't accept it
so what I'm talking about is when
someone tells you that you're lazy
instead of getting mad
say you're right I am being lazy and I'm
gonna do better and then
do better start waking up early start
getting after it work harder if you know
someone tells you that you're gluttonous
well then don't get mad about it be like
you know what I was going kind of ham on
the freaking you know chocolate pie or
whatever
and then stop eating the extra desserts
and and so that's a clear example of
what happens here of when you get
insulted but it really applies to like
anything anything that actually bothers
you
if you follow the thread of what's
bothering you to the truth then you can
actually deal with it
so when there's something that's
bothering you if you follow it and you
pull the thread to figure out why it's
actually bothering you then you can deal
with the problem
so often in this day and age we let our
emotions replace thought
we don't we just feel the emotion and
that's what we
utilize to react with
and by the way what do we react we don't
react by self-correcting react by
lashing out at other people
this is like politics today right this
is like social media today something
makes you mad you don't know why you're
mad but it makes you mad
and so you go on the attack and that is
what's wrong
instead of
I mean
not instead of but when you get angry
it's not a reason to lash out at other
people when you get angry it's actually
a signal
not to lash out but to look in
to look in to see where it is you are
troubled
as an individual human being that you
are letting something else dictate the
way you feel
don't get mad get curious get curious to
figure out why it is that you are so
angry about this thing
and if you can figure out why you're
actually getting mad
because maybe this person said something
political and I'm so mad that they said
it but then I pull through my action I'm
actually just jealous that they have
this or
um frustrated that they did that about
what I should have been like all those
things all the little ego things that
are probably gonna you're probably gonna
find at the end of the thread that you
pull yeah if you can figure that out
if you can look in instead of lashing
out
that's when you can make Corrections and
you will be in a much better situation
so that's interesting you because I
I never really thought of this until you
just said it right now where
the part about it kind of being true and
maybe you're insecure about it or
whatever like that made sense of course
and um but sometimes I'm like wait a
second but sometimes people will like
throw a jab or insult whatever and I
won't get mad if it's true or not I'll
get mad the fact that they chose to try
to insult me kind of a thing so and you
can and I can kind of separate it where
like if it's if if you're my friend and
you throw insults off all day that's how
I grew up like with you know with the
twin brothers or bro our whole
relationship was insults who could get
the better insult the funnier insult if
it's not funny it's just dumb
um so I was used to that part of things
but then sometimes it's like um you know
like let's say you just meet someone and
they get too comfortable with you and
then they throw insults it's like the
insult wasn't insulting at all but
you're mad that they they thought that
they were in any position to like have
that relationship with you kind of a
thing
of course say that last part again the
fact that they chose it's almost like
and here's my my point is going to be
there is that it still comes down to you
ego where
the insult wasn't insulting but the fact
that you chose to insult me is it's like
a personal affront doesn't matter how
you did it it's the fact that you did it
you know it's like that that usually is
things that like will bother me you know
but like bro you're not my
super good friend you don't have it like
that kind of a thing you know
or just someone who's just you know
someone who confronts you you know who
positions himself as your sort of enemy
socially or whatever it's like that's
the part that that's insulting it's
insane but either way
ego there you go that's what it is oh
yeah because I mean if someone's like
first of all I don't like I don't know
not a bunch of people like running
around trying to insult me are they
doing that to you I understand that
completely uh no no not currently of
course but I'm trying to think of all
the times that I'm like wait a second
like I did kind of get bothered by
someone like insulting me oh yeah and
that's the other thing is when you get
bothered yeah you're gonna get more
insults because you give you gave them
what they wanted
that reaction it worked bro nothing
better than smiling laughing off like
carry on dude don't get mad don't let
your ego get to you and look there's
nothing better
than actual confidence right to be like
oh yeah you're right I am kind of a
knuckle dragger the only times I've said
that in my life I am him deaf in a
meathead for sure yep like like just
cool someone's trying to insult me by
calling me a knuckle you freaking
knuckle dragger and no definitely
scraping them on the floor like what you
know what I mean yeah yeah and they're
right I am a knuckle dragger so it's
like cool like what else
right on let's rock and roll but yeah
just the the fact of instead of lashing
out looking in is gonna help you live a
lot of
yeah
I help with a lot of things so there you
go it's my advice for this week giving
advice advice column like you know like
that's what we're doing apparently today
yep well yeah so
trying to figure things out a little bit
that's true it's a mystery
um first question
oh it starts to email off I like to tell
you who I am so you understand where I'm
coming from I am Jonathan 14 years old
and I'm the youngest child of eight my
family is 100 conservative and Catholic
my whole life I've wanted
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the the Jocko underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you
general assistance at Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground